I still like to believe that that's
actually a myth which people don't
actually die we actually want something
that happens to other people it's an
ornament I think that is the great
mellowing of life isn't it so on shots
of all one of the things that we try to
do is summarize these kind of ecstatic
realizations I stumble upon something
fascinating and I want to explain it and
share it and kind of hold it in stasis
this guy right here my friend Jamie
wheel is the co-founder the flow Genome
Project and Jamie you did a TEDx talk
called from altered states to alter
traits and it's all about hacking the
flow state you are also creating a flow
dojo which is helping people reverse
engineer their flow States and create
these ecstatic states of mind in which
people perform their best and feel their
best so tell us about some of these
tools and techniques that you're
implementing in the flow dojo with
Steven Kotler what you guys doing sure
well what we're teeing up is the world's
first research and training facility
dedicated to ultimate human performance
or flow States okay and the premise is
what would happen if we took like the
hands-on Science Museum like the
Exploratorium okay here in San Francisco
sure right with all those sort of
kinetic exhibits the kids get to monkey
with and learn about bigger forces and
apply it to basically kinetics our
bodies and and sort of this notion of
that as we train our bodies and brains
to work really well together yes then
our waking cells yes I get to experience
more accurate information processing
greater resourcefulness and emotional
resilience okay and generally amplified
pattern recognition right perspective
holding yeah and therefore sort of in a
more increasingly sophisticated an
accurate decision-making flow states you
feel your best and you perform your best
elite athletes when they're in the zone
jazz musicians when they just literally
go crazy and you're just improvising
channeling almost now these states are
associated with these brief transitory
instances that we get to peek at nirvana
but what you're saying
is that now through advances in
technology psychology neurobiology
pharmaco and pharmacology drugs right we
now have the capacity we now have the
capacity to backdoor access these flow
States so that they're not half hazard
fleeting ephemeral states but that they
become part of the human experience on a
daily basis yeah for sure and so and so
that's the reverse-engineer part right
okay right so so in the past how we
would experience it would be it would be
I seeking a flow state I might be lucky
have one by dumb luck right or design
yeah but either way I'd have it and it
would come and go and then I'd come back
to me all right right so but easier than
ever to get high as hard as it's always
been to stay that way yeah yeah yeah the
perennial ennui right right curses
right back here grief dopamine hit back
here again oh I've orgasmed and now it's
over yeah what a moment of Rick Lera tea
and regret that is clary regret and
despair like the evolutionary impulses
cease to intoxicate me and hijack mine
my motor skills
I cannot stabilize ecstasy yeah
the goosebumps are gone as quickly as
they can yeah but you're talking about
like literally creating the conditions
where you can just keep surfing that way
aren't we acting almost Promethean i
mean your own work with Steven collar
talks about stealing fire like our human
beings prepared should they be allowed
to know the secret songs that
orchestrate the universe of the neuro
chemistry of lived experience do we get
to tweak and upgrade subjectivity you're
talking about right tweaking and
upgrading subjectivity yeah I would say
and add a multi perspectival in front of
that subjectivity and I think you're off
to the races and so how do we do it
flow dojo you design spaces you know
that the design is back I mean we're
talking about illogical design we're
talking harnessing feedback loops to
change behavior and change patterns yeah
I mean it's basically just think of it
as sort of the training center for
create like Ironman like imagine if in a
future sort of Tony Stark was like okay
I'm gonna put together the best
technologies to hyper trained or hyper
conditioned my physical capacities
cognitive skills vision visionary
tracking you just take physical fitness
out of the
kind of Beach muscles cosmetic and
aesthetic and you turn it into athletic
and Mura kinetic race you've just
completely just rebooted physical
culture and actually it's more of a
throwback to like 19th century Germany
and the gymnasium effects which is a
throwback to Plato in the original
academy and Pythagoras and that whole
crew right so this is a beautiful
Western tradition of radically embodied
cognition philosophy celebration
celebration the symposium right drinking
together right all of its elevation wine
women and song became that became the
Aquarian sex drugs and rock and roll yes
so we go on yes here we are
and so we go on we may contribute a
verse and all that jazz sure yes
this gets me really excited now one of
the things that you talked about in your
TEDx talk was how technology is allowing
us to pump dual awareness through
satellite dishes into iPhones beaming
brains and you talked about that
trajectory you talked about Bob Dylan
playing a small little concert and then
plugging is Stratocaster and beaming
electrified musical expression into a
hundred thousand Minds you know
paraphrasing but talked about the role
of technology and allowing us to to
literally radically extend these
insights and transformations to mediate
and tweak consciousness with tools and
technologies that right well I think I
think you pretty well said it I mean
it's that sense that we are able to
shape and prime our environments and are
psychosomatic experiences yes so with
music with deep thumping bass and
incredibly high image amplify so
different directional sounds yeah right
yeah projection mapping of incredible
high definition
you know resolution and ridiculous
especially when synchronized with music
and beats you start you start
dislocating all of our geospatial or
proprioceptive reference points okay so
I'm not even sure what I'm looking at
where did the horizon line go what's
happening and it doesn't even matter
this is we're just rolling with this
well those things and then you do the
sync the syncopation yeah and the
different beats per minute which also in
train exactly features is that is that
old was it wasn't your humus Kepler it
was one of those early watchmakers who
remember discovered that the pendulums
all would synchronize in his what in the
clock clock shop okay watch shop okay
and anybody realizes they all
synchronize to the rate of the largest
pendulum so there is this coherence
effect around waveforms okay
and when we're harnessing that we're
exploiting that for our own gains for
our own bliss yeah I'm like that I mean
we've always used tools and technologies
to create bliss I mean we use language
to write poetry we use musical
instruments to create melodies that act
as wallpapers for our minds to use your
term from last night but like what new
forms of human beauty and human
subjectivity will become possible as we
create a new generation of mind-melding
technologies you know new drugs I mean
now we're seeing a renaissance in
America with the use of psychedelics
being more widely acceptable as
psychotherapeutic tools for people with
PTSD but the article in The New Yorker
written by Michael Pollan talked about
the idea of making well paper well
making well people better yeah we can
actually create a new generation of
smart drugs and mind mind-altering
chemicals both internal ones and
external ones that we can use to make
well people better but it's not just
about fixing an affliction but it's
about expanding what it means to be and
perceive and be human you know I keep
coming back to this idea that human
beings you know we're getting better
we're figuring you know we're looking up
up the skirt of nature looking into
under the hood of our own brains and
we're getting increasingly better at
mapping these ecstatic states these flow
States and we're getting increasingly
better at mediating these ecstatic
states right so I want you to talk to me
about the poetry of these ecstatic
states know in the sense that like of
course we want to mediate ecstasy
because ecstasy is the most beautiful
thing in the world you know it's
standing at the playa Burning Man or
going into an IMAX theater and listening
to some beautiful Hans Zimmer score that
moves you to tears or the grief of that
concert that you were talking about
yesterday remember remember what you
were talking about that the band is
going to play with fish like talk to me
about that place why we go there and why
it's good to want to go there the
nobility of what flow genome is doing
well I mean I would say what we are
hoping to do yes it start a conversation
and build a community
people that of like minds that uh
passionate as well
yeah about the upper limits of human
human possibility the upper limits of
human possibility I mean one of the
things that you guys are going to talk
about you and Steven Kotler in your new
book is the altered States economy right
for sure okay the effect that people
spend upwards of billions trillions of
dollars to alter their consciousness to
feel good
twenty bucks give me an Indiana Jones
thrill ride you know here's a hundred
bucks send me to a dream within a dream
in Inception you know here's a hundred
dollars take me to the neverending story
there's something we're willing to pay
for and labor for and so you're saying
we barely have glimpsed was possible and
you're probing the contours of the upper
limits of human experience I just want
you to tell me about that dance like oh
I I I love what you guys are doing I
want to turn my colander into a chalice
I want to mediate my ecstasy I want III
you know I want I want everybody to be
able to experience that what we need to
do what's missing where where are we on
that trajectory right now yeah I mean I
think we're we're right there with all
the parts and puzzle pieces and as far
as literally and reliably being able to
put people into as expansive and
interesting states of awareness as they
can manage and and at the same time
that's not the fail point the fail point
is what it's always been which is just
human discipline and so we get
distracted and we get knocked off the
path and we get bored we get frustrated
we dabble we hack and we obsess and we
crash and and that notion of like we
think it should be endless peak moments
right instead of the plateaus of mastery
practice until the next one you'll get
in it you'll get an integration which
often happens in that theta state and in
fact theta depending on whose research
you're following gamma bursts right
those integrative gestalt aha the
Eureka's can only occur in a substrate
of theta ways right so that's one other
thing say that again
Eureka moments can only what so the the
the bursts of gamma waves of
neuroelectric activity is what is
correlated with the
Stolte integrative experience seeing the
whole eureka aha I got aerial view big
yep sure guess Kazan Shazam right and
that occurs only on a substrate of theta
wave activity so that's where that
particular bolt of lightning goes so
putting yourself into a theta state on
purpose through respiratory regulation
through any kind of neuro or biofeedback
through cardiac controls and practices
right through through through any of
those components you're then putting
yourself you're like Ben Franklin flying
the the kite with the key in a storm
right you're right there waiting for it
to hit how often do you get it goodness
gracious life I mean I feel like I I'm
blessed with getting to experience it as
often as I pay attention to it okay
which very that requires the kind of
priming - you got to be there you got to
be there you got to be present you have
to have the cognitive resources to
witness and trigger yellow state I mean
yeah and I think ultimately I think my
experience of in this maybe this is just
me maybe I just have had this coming in
spades but I have found that the more
time you spend in those kind of
effortless effort conditions the more
important it is to have your house in
order so they sort of I don't I mean I
have no presumption is whether this is a
universal truth or just my experience
but it seems like the there's a price
for experiencing it and the price for
experiencing it is acting on the
information acting on the goodness truth
and beauty that you apprehend while
there and then trying to live up your
damnedest to that example and
inspiration when we're back here and if
you skip that step it's on your mortal
soul the next time you go back to the
wishing well
ha